powerless are they important a lot of
people sure seem to think they are and a
whole bunch of others really don't agree
that they are at all now as some of you
I'm sure are aware a while back I made
an entire series trying to calculate the
exact power levels of different
characters and it was a fundable time
with my final verdict being that they
don't much matter and on a number of
occasions I've made videos addressing
this particular section of the online
fandom that seems to be transfixed on an
individual specific power number beyond
anything else that's right Scouters
numbers numbers numbers numbers Dragon
Ball Z is all about them apparently and
as soon as they lost track on those said
Scouter numbers the plot start to lose
consistency right well yes but it's a
little more complicated than that
actually to me those numbers honestly
don't much matter to a degree today I
want to look at what power levels mean
in this story how integral they are in
almost every single shown in battle
series and to demonstrate this I will be
using Dragon Ball as my guinea pig power
levels are one of the most divisive and
popular topics to discuss
in this community and today I'm here to
see just how important they really are
[Music]
Dragon Ball Z was filled with big buff
dudes postulating on each other
screaming and making sure everyone knew
just how strong they really were and
eventually in that story we learn about
Scouters a mechanical power reading
device that gave each character a number
representing how strong their energy
level was relative to the rest of the
cast that was measured in other words
the bigger the number the stronger the
guy it made things absurdly simple which
was intentional for a number of reasons
creating a very easy to understand
dynamic for everyone who was watching to
get behind again
this seems overly straightforward and
not particularly revolutionary so why is
it so divisive well there seems to be a
divide online between those that deem
power levels to be important and those
that think how I love us not both I mean
check it out right I put up this poll on
Twitter simply asking the question if
they were important and even that was
enough to star flame war in the comment
section between both sides of this
argument and the reason is both sides of
this argument are arguing past each
other both are correct and wrong at the
same time so to kick things off let's
look at white power levels are important
in a show like Dragon Ball if you're new
to anime or more specifically Dragonball
you'll soon realize how important the
strength of any given character within
that show is or more specifically in the
case of Dragon Ball how big their power
level number is broadly speaking this
sense the audience is given for how
strong a character is is a vitally
important aspect of what makes a fight
scene captivating but more importantly
what makes a fight scene work this sense
of context given in these scenes how
strong a character is relative to
another is called subtext in the case of
Dragon Ball subtext is a deeper meaning
derived by the viewer that the writer
didn't directly express through dialogue
in that scene for example during the
22nd World Martial Arts Tournament an
early Dragon Ball this subtext is the
reason we know Goku is extremely strong
and on another level long before
fighting piccolo jr. in the final it
isn't directly said but through context
clues and clever framing it's
communicated to us long before the to
square off one of the single most
annoying things overconfident writers do
is to fill their scenes with complex
dialogue ramblings when a writer things
come
language is complex and therefore makes
a story complex my head falls into my
hands a story isn't complex just because
the language is complicated in fact I'd
argue it's convoluted overly simplistic
and viciously uninteresting telling a
view or how to feel is the quickest way
to make a story in software be boring so
in other words if the story doesn't have
subtext it's going to really struggle to
find its own legs this show don't tell
part of storytelling has unfortunately
becomes something of a meme lately but
what it actually adds to a scene is
staggering if the viewer or reader can
discover for themselves through subtext
and context clues what is being
communicated they can enjoy the product
much more easily it's the difference
between lecturing and experiencing and a
great example of this can be observed
with our introduction to Frieza people
are cowering around him he sits on this
floating throne his minions are doing
exactly as he says without delay from
his actions and the subtext of the scene
we can understand that he is incredibly
powerful dangerous and cruel remove that
subtlety and you get a scene like this
hey I'm Frieza I am the single strongest
person in the universe I am hoping that
this will intimidate you so that you
give me the Dragon Ball easier through
but what does this have to do with power
levels
well everything actually and it's all to
do with subtext the fight between Vegeta
and Goku in the Saiyan saga is one of my
absolute favorite fight scenes of all
time I made an entire video explaining
why I think it works so well and why I
love it and through making that video I
discovered a hefty number of people
preferred the rematch in the Buu saga
not only do I disagree but I actually
never really loved that fight if a fight
is great it should work both in the
manga and in the anime and I'm not
saying their fight doesn't work at all
in the Buu saga but I am saying that if
you take the nice animation supply from
the time period and replaced it with the
original manga version it loses I think
a lot of its luster and the more
entertaining fight between the two
becomes all the more clear at least to
me and this is all thanks to context now
there's absolutely nothing wrong with
preferring the second fight to the first
again at the end of the day it's
entirely subjective and there's plenty
going on in terms of character in the
second fight to hold your interest
specifically on the side of a jitta and
with his new tied to poverty and Boo and
whatever but for me there's virtually no
sense of how strong someone is relative
to the next at least compared to their
first fight prior to their second fight
there's no context there's no set of
circumstances that illuminate to us just
how strong everyone is relative to each
other the gia says he's weaker than Goku
Vegeta says that Gohan isn't as strong
as he used to be
Goku doesn't say how strong he is at all
which is actually good but the two
fights we do see prior to Goku and
Vegeta fighting are just squash matchups
to demonstrate that the Z Warriors are
on another level entirely to what Bobby
was prepared for which is a cool little
visual but tells us nothing about them
we get some indication that Vegeta isn't
happy with his standing compared to Goku
once he stomps his way through yacon but
that's it he then gets bobbidi magic to
make him stronger how much stronger I
don't know how much stronger was Goku
than Vegeta before Bobby's magic I lost
a little there's honestly no way of
knowing this in this Saiyan saga we all
have a clear understanding of how strong
everyone is and it doesn't depend on
Skyler numbers either even if you take
them away it still works through
fighting with Raddatz we know that
piccolo is roughly the same level as
Goku go on is stronger than all of the
Earth's fighters but it's conditional on
his mood and once the fight with the
Saiyans takes place we get a preliminary
set of matches with the Z boyars and the
Cybermen and since each Cyberman is the
same level gauging how strong each
fighter is relative to each other
becomes an extremely easy enterprise as
they are fighting effectively the same
opponent piccolo is far far stronger
than Yamcha tension done by passive the
Cybermen entirely and fights nappa all
these choices tell us something about
the characters and how they fight and
how confident they really are how their
abilities work and when emotions become
involved how strong they can become
skyrockets because we know that piccolo
improves since his fight with Raddatz
when Goku shows up we have a terrific
sense of just how much more powerful
Goku is when he arrives and takes out
nappa and since Napa is acting as the
lapdog to Vegeta we can only assume how
much more powerful Vegeta is then and
having this comprehensive understanding
of how strong everyone is relative to
one another
helps the fight itself between Goku and
Vegeta feel less like a squabble between
two men and more like a titanic clash
between two demigods so why are power
levels not important a Scouter is a
physical manifestation or prop used to
illustrate one thing
nothing more to show us all how
short-sighted the villainous caste truly
are refusing to hone or listen to their
abilities and senses instead relying
exclusively on this mechanical device to
advise them on how capable a fighter is
that they are about to square off
against and as I said at the beginning
it's an absurdly simple metaphor it's
never directly said to our faces but
again because subtext is important how
many times do you need to see a Scouter
explode off some guys shocked and
terrified face to understand that they
are essentially useless in combat
outside of maybe helping you to locate
someone but then again that's still a
technique that's possible to learn and
Dragon Ball but whatever point is
Scouters specifically our narrative
device used to emphasize the bad guys
shortcomings to show that true passion
tenacity and skill can overcome natural
ability and evil and tidy up some loose
ends here and there when appropriate we
don't need to understand exactly how
strong Goku is in numerical expression
to enjoy a fight no one did for Golan's
fight with cell and it was one of the
most popular clashes in the show's
history and that in and of itself
highlights what is actually important
and understanding of how strong a
character is relative to those they
engage with throughout the story I mean
if you really think about it if literal
power levels actually mattered that much
then that would mean that the fights in
og Dragonball wouldn't be anything to
write home about and let me tell you one
thing they're amazing and they
absolutely are effectively dishing out
the information to a viewer through
subtext for them to then infer
themselves is the key to building
excitement tension and epic fights I'm
gonna run through some good and bad
fight scenes now and Dragonball to point
out why some of them work and others
don't like at all
the whole reason the Namek and frieza
saga worked as well as it did was
largely due to the tension the story
effectively implemented but wouldn't
mechanic that dictated a lot of that
tension was in fact the sense of power
each character emitted for instance
[Music]
the first opponents Crillon and go on
face off against anomic weren't someone
that was stronger than them they were -
grunts that show up and try to take them
down at the very beginning but both are
quickly discarded this served two
functions within the story to set a
baseline in terms of power for the two
point-of-view characters at this point
in the story Gohan and krillen but to
also let the viewer know and the
characters know that they have Scudders
and like the sands did on earth meaning
they'll find them too if they're not
careful and so using this information
and their own abilities to sense ki they
now know the world is filled with
impossibly strong opponents and thus the
hide-and-seek cat-and-mouse game begins
the fights in resurrection F are an
absolute unmitigated mess and before I
get into this I need to make it known
that I'm not saying involving classic
characters is it nice it is but it needs
to make sense first why is Roshi
involved surely he would die with no
explanation our context clues he's
involved and no one seems to question
anything additionally we have no idea
how strong the actual Frieza force here
even is so why are they fighting it
would be like if the Saiyan saga started
out with a thousand Cybermen and they
kept fighting them in groups for five
episodes that sounds ridiculous right
and when Goku fights Frieza in his base
they literally talk during the fight
about how strong they are now both
during and before the fight not just to
show off as is common in Dragon Ball but
to actually inform the viewer because we
have no idea how strong the guys are
otherwise and that's pretty much why
that fight doesn't work the fight in
Dragon Ball super bra worked because we
got to step through the various forms
like building blocks or stepping stones
following broglie's journey to discover
how strong he really is and can be
instead of that movie having a villain
beginning the fight setting the
benchmark
Broly is actually on the backfoot which
changes the entire dynamic of the fight
on a fundamental level and as brouilly
scales higher and higher the movie
respects the audience's ability to
understand the levels of transformation
and that each level represents a higher
level of physical output there's also
significantly fewer moving parts which
makes the fight a lot better I think as
many of you know I spent an ungodly
amount of time going through Dragon
Balls grease
which is utterly filled to bursting with
fight scenes that have no sense of
context waste or tension with regards
the fighters involved at the very end
omega shenron is fighting goku in Super
Saiyan 4 and he is decimating him but
later in the fight we see base form kid
Goku holding his blast back because the
audience and I'm assuming the writers
have no idea how strong these two
combatants actually are and the only
ideas they had were of a cool snap shot
scene but they had no idea how to make
it work within the internal logic of the
fight thus it becomes impossible to make
a compelling fight scene with Dragon
Balls even if you want to look elsewhere
other shows give the viewer that context
that colours the entire show thereafter
one punch man has a ridiculously easy to
understand power system simply put if
Saitama tries he wins and this is quite
literally established at the conclusion
of the very first scene in the story
vaccine man shows up posturing as a top
tier villain displaying all the power
and strength a substantial threat might
very well have and without his second
thought
Saitama fliction out of existence this
acts as a very simple message to the
audience that Saitama is quite literally
if he so chooses the one punch man armed
now with that knowledge the audience has
a very different dynamic with Saitama
every time he's on screen instead of
wondering if he will win we start to
look at each cocky villain he encounters
waiting eagerly for the moment they
realize just how screwed they really are
in Dragonball power levels as we know
them were introduced as soon as the
character Frieza had his presence felt
in the series they were certainly a fun
sight to behold and don't get me wrong a
large number of people myself included
can have fun trying to figure out how
insanely strong characters have become
throughout the show using their provided
metrics but Dragon Ball and other
battles Shonen have much more important
power systems to concern themselves with
that affect the narrative directly and
while I don't think this size of
someone's a literal battle power level
matters as much as others might think
the scouter power levels did happen to
be the canary in the coal mine when it
came to consistency in Dragon Ball as
soon as it became more difficult to
gauge the strength of a character ie
in the Android saga and thereafter there
viewers ability to make sense of how
strong each character was relative to
each other
suffered greatly and has explained
earlier in the video having a
comprehensive understanding of this is
essential if you want your audience to
get involved and to understand the
standings of a given altercation this is
why in the Android saga and thereafter
we are greeted by more superficial power
boosts than there ever have been in the
series before I say superficial because
we don't actually know anything about
their strengths we just know that they
are stronger now and as we Traverse into
later sections of the Buu saga Dragon
Ball G and eventually Dragon Ball super
the issues exacerbate exponentially and
that's incredibly unfortunate I think
Dragon Ball super and even she had some
interesting fights but they were often
bogged down by a lack of subtext and
overall understanding and so while
numeric car levels are not important by
design and understanding and respect for
the importance of power levels is thanks
for watching
[Music]